okay so let's be crystal clear um uh
what vulnerability is actually requires
strength to do
it requires unbelievable strength to to
to
come into a meeting and say i'm
struggling with this covet thing um i'm
not sleeping and
and i and i and i fear that i'm not
there for you guys
um and i'm not sure i'm not sure what to
do
i mean that requires unbelievable
strength to be able to say that to
someone
and so and so i let us call it strength
to be vulnerable
not weakness to be vulnerable um if if
um if we are receiving feedback that
we're not being vulnerable
then maybe it's true and maybe our team
is is what they're really saying is
please lead us because we feel that
you're not leading us
i mean i think that's an indication and
if you don't know how to do it
um ask for ask for help call people up
and say i know i need to do this and i
don't even know the first thing to do
and start small you don't have to go
crazy
and being vulnerable doesn't mean uh you
know
like you're talking to your therapist in
a meeting it doesn't mean
letting it all out it doesn't mean
broadcasting everything
um what it means is being honest about
the the daily machinations
um it's totally fine for a leader to say
um i don't know what the future looks
like
i have a vision i think i know what it
takes to get there
but i know i can't do it alone i know
it's going to take all of us
i think a very very easy dipping your
toe into vulnerability
uh is coveted you know um
to say i've never gone through anything
like this before
and i there's a side of me that's kind
of figuring it out as i go along and i
need your help and i need your patience
um you know to dip your it's an amazing
opportunity covert has
has offered because nobody thinks you're
weak saying i don't know what's going to
happen
uh you they think you're being honest um
so i think
you need to start experimenting and you
need someone
preferably in the company who who you
trust who can give you guidance in other
words
to call them up afterwards and say how
did that go you know
you know you need spies um to say is
that being well received was i okay
yeah and even to say out loud i don't
know how to do this i'm not good at this
i've
i've never i used to think vulnerability
was stupid and weak
and i'm learning that it's an expression
of strength and i'm going to experiment
with it
simply saying that is a step to being
vulnerable to simply say i don't know
how to be vulnerable to the team
but i want to try because i know it's
important uh that's where i would
recommend starting
yeah is there a potential danger around
this
that by being vulnerable in this time of
uncertainty
people are actually looking for
something to hang on to right now
and by you coming and saying look i'm
vulnerable i'm worried i'm you know but
i'm not sleeping i don't know what's
going to happen etc etc
that's what you need that's not actually
necessarily very helpful for what peop
for people who are also strongly worried
about the future of the company they
look up and go
geez well if the boss of the company is
this stressed out you know
i should be really worried um is that a
potential
problem or could be an issue goes back
to my story about cynthia which is
being strong all the time is not
necessarily
healthy especially when everybody knows
it's just not true
um i think the difference is is i i
i don't know what's going to happen in
the future and then stopping
what we're looking is for leadership not
certainty
what we're looking for is guidance and
direction not necessarily
answers so when somebody says i don't
know what the future holds
but i know that if we follow this vision
and we work together and we're open to
each other's ideas
we will get through this that's what
we're that the leadership part is not
the
i don't know what we're going to do and
this is a difficult time the leadership
part is
and here's what we're going to do here's
a plan and we might have to adjust along
the way
what we're looking for is someone to
guide us and point in a direction
but the expression of the vulnerability
uh is is essential for people to want to
come along i think